qui a entendu quoi que j'ai entendu
quelqu'un dire hey oh ça grouille de
poisson par ici n'importe quel poisson
peut faire clients juste là là ou là à
là bonjour papa tories ou santé par an
bonjour j'ai perdu ma femme ou les as tu
vu pour la dernière fois j'ai ouï je
cherchais quelque chose j'ai d'accord je
comprends vous avez rendez-vous jeu des
troubles de la mémoire immédiate
cette famille enfin je crois vos
missions
on y tue alors faire attention regardes
quoi ça elle a été enlevé on a du monde
mais dans ce procès même parce que c'est
un hôpital pour les postes au mois c'est
donc c'est pas si simple quand même vous
êtes coincés ici je sens mes paroles
comme c'est triste car je t'avais pas
super g il est à l'intérieur les seuls
ballet on va avoir besoin de ton sonar
jeu ridicule série attendre à ma maman
est là qui vont choisir de au hasard et
surtout si on s'est dit ça pour rire
quand ils font chute comme ça ils ont
sûrement alors faire des choses comme
une espèce de géants des codes et les
normes des tentacules et faisait pas
évident et aussi précises mais pourquoi
pas oui
quelque part j'ai une famille je les
retrouverai jamais tout seul un bond
aurait accroche noir jean quéveau j'ai
pas envie qu'on me touche
désolé c'est pas grave ça peut arriver à
tout le monde et pas avant
lui fait confiance sur ma propre fille
ont sapé qui toi elle a la tête dans sa
gueule m
naj drôlement toi maman
ça veut dire qu'on va bientôt se séparer
avec tori comment j'ai pu croire que je
n'es rien tu vas bientôt retrouver tes
parents et comme tu les auras retrouver
sur un chez moi
ce sont les lions de mer de dangereux
prédateurs ils peuvent pour dire comment
ce temps potts ou si elle va sortir
vous avez aucun souci à vous faire